وبينما رحب الامين العام للنيتو بالقرار
الامريكيه الغربي دعائي الى تقديم الاسلحه
الثقيله لاوكرانيا لضمان عدم فوزي بوتن
بهذه الحرب وشدد على ان الروس يحشدون
قوتهم ويكثفون انتاج الاسلحه ويخططون
لهجوم جديد ضد اوكرانيا اذا هو تصعيد جديد
في سياق دعم النيترو لاوكرانيا
مع ضغط دول غربيه على اوكرانيا لتغيير
سريع في تكتيكاتها بعيدا عن معركه
استنزافا داريا شرقا يقترحوا مسؤولون
اوكرانيون ان ترسل دول الناتو اكثر من 100
دبابه المانيه من طراز لبرد الولايات
المتحده سترسل واحدا و 30 دبابه قتال من
طراز ابرام 1 وتقدره صحيفه التلجراف فانا
الغربه على استعدادا لارسال ما يصل الى
200 دبابه قتاليه الى اوكرانيا فضل عن نحو
900 ناقله جند مدره من طرا برادلي
وسترايكر واموردر تم نشرها في اوكرانيا
وفقا للبنتاجوني يقول قاده عسكري دون
امريكيون لي نيويورك تايمز ان هذه الاسلحه
ستستخدم في حرب خاطفه للسلاء على سلسله من
المدن جنوب اوكرانيا وتنقل واشنطن بوست عن
وزير الدفاع الامريكي ان الهدف الواقعيه
لاوكرانيا هذا العام سيكون استعاده مناطق
الجسر البري بين روسيا والقرم والتي
احتلتها روسيا العمل الماضيه